il y à 40 millions d'années des requins
évolué ici dans la géographie marine de
ce qui allait devenir paris
[Musique]
sur la colline du trocadéro un chantier
la mise à jour des roches fossiles
incrusté de coquillages et de dents de
requins mais ce n'était pas une fouille
archéologique qui motivait les
entrepreneurs derrière des palissades un
projet ambitieux est en train de prendre
forme
reconstruire totalement le vieil
aquarium du trocadéro pour en faire un
des plus beaux et des plus modernes
d'europe
le site est classé les consignes de la
mairie de paris sont claires les
promoteurs ne doivent toucher aucun
arbre et laisser le parc tel qu'il était
avant les travaux le chantier entame sa
troisième année mais presque rien ne
transparaît à la surface comme pour un
sous marin c'est dans les sous-sols que
tout se passe
théoriquement l'aquarium doit être livré
dans trois mois mais aujourd'hui
l'urgence est de remplir les bassins
a priori il nous reste qu'à ouvrir le
robinet mais une armada de problèmes
techniques refait surface chaque jour
cet homme qui s'amuse des querelles
incessantes c'est pascal coûtant pascal
et le biologiste en chef de l'aquarium
avec son équipe il sera responsable de
tous les pensionnaires qui séjourneront
ici c'est à dire plus de quinze mille
poissons dont des requins des raies et
de centaines d'autres espèces
les sous sols du trocadéro sont percés
de 43 bagues d'exposition l'équipe de
pascal coûtant relève le pari d'emmener
des visiteurs dans un tour du monde de
milieu marin qu en quelques pages
bientôt tout sera noyé c'est peut-être
la dernière fois que pascal coûtant peut
marcher au fond du grand bassin ici on a
voulu recréer un grand grand bassin qui
va faire de 1400 mètres cube le but
c'est de procurer du rêve aux visiteurs
c'est à dire que l'objectif des
architectes c'était de le découvrir
petit à petit c'est à dire qu'on a la
grande faille là haut une grande ville
verticale qui va nous montrer juste
subrepticement du tout là haut la barre
le passage des poissons
ensuite on va découvrir le bassin à
travers un autre aquarium
donc on verra juste les requins dans le
fond d'un aquarium et petit à petit
comme ça on va découvrir tout le bassin
c'est à dire qu'après on aura les
hublots ici après on sera sous la grotte
pour avoir une trentaine de requins
plein de sortes doré et de convoi quand
on va être dans le tunnel on voit les
nuages de ré qui vont nous passer au
dessus de la tête des grands requins qui
vont passer je pense que ce sera
vraiment
l'autre les paysages marins s'élève en
béton des grottes les stalactites et des
orgues basaltiques apparaissent sous les
trouver le des artistes des concepteurs
c'est vraiment leur idée c'est eux qui
voulaient mettre ça donc on essaye de
concilier foi les musiques et les
aspects décoratifs et là c'est vraiment
crucial au niveau de la décoration
tata combien de temps pour sculpter en
fait j'ai la journée donc à 14h que
manière que j'ai réussi ou pas ces morts
c'est fini ça sera du plomb c'est comme
ça depuis neuf mois mais ces derniers
est simple ouais
on a on a cherché sur des photos sur
internet sur toute une bibliothèque de
diabo qu'on a on a choisi des
échantillons différents types de roches
méditerranéenne on leur a dit voilà
dentelle bassin on veut que ça
représente ce décor là et donc le
sculpteur a réalisé avec son talent
d'artiste en plus c'est à dire qu'il ya
chaque chaque artiste chaque décorateur
a utilisé sa propre touche dans des
bassins pour donner une personnalité au
bassin pour mettre de la vie dans ces
rochers haskell a lancé un appel
d'offres à tous les professionnels de la
pêche le bac méditerranée sera peuplée
par gérard carreau d'âne aux marchands
de rêves et de couleurs sur la côte
d'azur
ce qui serait dommage de rater en
méditerranée si les couleurs les
propriété fluorescente certaines espèces
qu'on faut-il être plongeur ou pêcheurs
pour connaître et pour imaginer
lorsqu'on est honnête au fond on se dit
tiens çà çà çà va avoir de la gueule on
va mettre ce nul ibrahim omar être cette
hormone ou aux manettes on s'interroge
avec la lumière on va arriver à faire
quelque chose de génial va faire rêver
les gens
[Musique]
gérard carreau des noues termine
aujourd'hui sa campagne de pêche
il ne lui manque plus qu'une dernière
prise pour honorer son contrat avec le
trocadéro des créatures essentiel auquel
pourtant les visiteurs date mario ne
prête jamais attention il est décrit qui
va ça consomme les détritus c'est bon ça
qu'ils appellent des traits qui volent
et alain gect dans tous les bacs
parce que si un jour il ya une personne
qui est mort qui est qui qui restait
sous un caillou que tu ne vois pas il va
être beaucoup plus vite a éliminé par
ces éléments que si pourri dans le bac
c'est pas vraiment ce n'est peut-être
pas vraiment génial pour les germes
pathogènes que ça peut que ça peut
générer
vice champion du monde de plongée gérard
carreau danos est installée au bout des
chantiers navals de la ciotat dans les
profondeurs de ses filets la collection
automne hiver de poisson est au complet
la touche finale d'une traque de
plusieurs mois pour présenter les plus
belles pièces et d'actes il obtient il
est prévu pour partir au trocadéro à
paris
si c'est la chance d'avoir une personne
comme ça parce que c'est relativement
rare en à 2 3 dans l'année et dans cet
état acclimater est parfait comme ça
c'est une aubaine parce que c'est pas
évident du tout
dans les réserves d'un artisan de la mer
les poissons sont à l'étroit
ils occupent ils moindres recoins ce qui
commence à poser problème
ça y est la grosse comme un acquis des
nommés pour munich et ce serait bien que
les poissons destinés au trocadéro qui a
pris un petit peu de retard puisse
puisse rentrer sur paris
tant qu'on n'est pas mieux structuré on
est un petit peu de tenue par la
capacité de capture aux d'autant qu'on
peut pas mettre n'importe qui avec
n'importe quoi il ya quand même des
normes conditionne de compatibilité à
respecter entre les spécimens et puis il
peut même y en avoir qui me bouffe les
autres certains poissons vont se faire
avaler d'autres vont se reproduire
plusieurs fois avant de rejoindre paris
le chantier prend de plus en plus de
retard
gérard carreau dan n'est pas le seul à
piétiner
il ya bien deux mois de retard quand
même le repérage des aciers le mans
depuis un an mais c'est pas fait pour ça
que je suis là à attendre
voilà
l'embouteillage menace n'est pas
question pour pascal coûtant de freiner
ses commandes de poisson
on a un aquarium qui est consacrée à la
faune guyanaise donc on va essayer de de
s'approvisionner au brésil pour avoir
les poissons qui vont dans ce berceau de
la jouerie robson viennent du brésil où
ils ont créé une société d'élevage et de
captures de poissons d'ornement
comme avec chacun de ses fournisseurs en
marge de la liste pascal formule un
souhait un vieux rêve
la capture d'un requin
[Musique]
la commande en poches géo vie met le cap
sur le brésil et ses 8000 km de côtes
elle rejoint ses bureaux à natal dans
l'état du nordiste
la pêche là bas est en plein essor
la société de jouerie et robson veut
profiter de cet élan
elle propose des poissons d'ornement les
investis dans l'aquaculture et
l'exportation
tout reste à faire pourtant malgré un
énorme potentiel
le brésil occupe seulement le 27e rang
mondial des producteurs de poissons la
pêche est très souvent artisanales
une aubaine pour hobson qui traquent
jusque dans les gares dote du pot des
spéciales du prix si je pense qu'il ya
beaucoup de poissons comme celui ci il
faudra en trouver
voyez le jaune il est superbe si vous
pouvez en attraper on vous les achètera
tous il y a des marrons par ici mais
nous voulons des jaunes avec des petites
taches noires comme celui ci alors si
vous en trouvez nous on n'en veut oui
c'est un bail à coup un jour y robson
sillonnent le pays
la pêche aux petits poissons a été
rapidement lancé ils ont le temps
d'organiser leur chasse aux requins on
va voir carlos qui pêchent le requin
depuis plus de 20 ans c'est le seul pari
si il le recherche pour sa viande mais
il lui arrive aussi dans l'attrapé de
vivant pour rencontrer carlos
il faut aller jusqu'au cap son rock la
plage du brésil la plus proche de
l'afrique des requins seulement des
requins non non non non on rapporte
aussi d'autres pièces bon ben je vous
souhaite un bon voyage
est ce qu'ils sont un succès
carlos possède deux choses une
expérience de 25 années passées en mer
et un bateau tout à lui un sacré capital
le brésil compte 50 millions de pauvres
près d'un sur deux vit dans le nordouest
faudrait que vous veniez quand on pêche
on passe quatre ou cinq jours en mer et
quand on revient notre distraction c'est
ça en jouets en bois parce que le métier
difficile vraiment la mer est difficile
le travail est difficile on doit de
l'argent on en doit beaucoup et pour
payer nos dettes il faut qu'on reste en
mer malgré les tempêtes et les orages
mais indique temps d'une horde est la
firme on ne meurt de faim ici que si
l'on refuse de pêcher carlos ghosn est
une zone à une dizaine d'heures de
navigation ou le bateau aura une chance
de croiser la route des requins
des centaines d'âmes sont vont descendre
jusqu au fond c'est le début d'une
longue chasse qui va durer plusieurs
jours
[Musique]
sur le chantier parisien les ouvriers
achèvent l'aménagement du grand bassin
avec la pose du dernier hublot on scelle
la fin de deux ans de travail
un soulagement pour jean françois bateau
le pilote du chantier sachez pas à mon
avis un truc comme ça
gros sabots moi j'ai pas trop - 3
millions celle là donc quand on serait
content des deux côtés qui font presque
50 mètres carrés 30 cm d'épaisseur 24
tonnes c'est le prix d'une belle petite
maison c'est pas grave je pourrais
remplacer le hublot mais pas vous
mariani vient du colorado
donc là il vient
un petit peu spécialement pour installer
deux derniers outrages des gens capables
de fabriquer des vitrages à cette taille
là donc pas celui-là c'est pas le bon
exemple mais ce qu'on peut avoir en les
plus gros il y en a deux ou trois ans
ont deux trois 2 1 go japon et aux états
pour l'instant ça ne ressemble pas
vraiment mers du sud
et parce qu'elle en est convaincu ses 43
bac auront les couleurs et l'atmosphère
des plus beaux fonds marins c'est le mai
dès 18h
comme c'est un mélange entre l'eau douce
et l'eau de mer c'est un milieu très
riche en oiseaux plancton et
phytoplancton et donc il ya beaucoup à
manger donc il ya beaucoup de petits
poissons c'est un milieu très important
parce qu'en fait c'est le la nurserie de
des récifs coralliens à des milliers de
kilomètres de là dans le nord est
brésilien
d'autres zones travail pour l'aquarium
embauché par jury et robson 7 de
pêcheurs se sont endettés pour acheter
leur propre barque et fouille sans
relâche les eaux troubles de la mangrove
[Musique]
un hippocampe
c'est une sacrée bonne rencontre pour
johnny sand il en recevra environ 2
euros
un cinquième du prix facturé à
l'aquarium pour survivre ici je dois
travailler du lundi au lundi
je démarre la journée quand lamar est au
plus bas
je pourrais pas embarquer sur un bateau
de pêche
ce serait trop fatigant pour moi le
poissons d'ornement
c'est exactement ce qui me choque et ça
ne m'empêche pas de prendre aussi du
poisson pour le manger mais parfois je
plonge deux ou trois jours de suite sans
rien trouver
[Musique]
sous l'eau diani seule file à toute
vitesse sans un regard pour les poissons
commun ou vénéneux
[Musique]
en
à chacun sa technique et ses armes
johnson a opté pour la simplicité d'une
bouteille découper
[Musique]
dans ses mains le piège est imparable la
cueillette va se prolonger tout
l'après-midi une récolte payante
robson l'associé de jury vient prendre
livraison d'une vingtaine de poissons
multicolores mais surtout d'une
demi-douzaine d'hippocampes
c'est porteur pour sceller ces types
qu'on paie très recherchés c'est une
bonne affaire commerciale
il vaut entre 10 et 12 dollars sur le
marché
on en trouve par ici l'institut de la
pêche au brésil
l'ibama rld est en train d'instaurer des
quotas annuels pour stopper la pêche
intensive à chaque entreprise de pêche
que ma quadra s'il a droit à 1000
l'hippocampe par an
au trocadéro
des dizaines de kilomètres de tuyaux
vont pomper l'eau de cet étonnant sous
marins
[Musique]
pour commercer là
plus de quatre millions de litres d'eau
à ça les a propulsés dans tous les
bassins
quatre millions de litres d'eau à
purifier et à dessaler avant de la
rejeter de l'eau de l'air la vie n'y a
pas que des poissons il ya aussi des
invertébrés et surtout il ya les coraux
c'est magique les coraux cessé d animaux
extrêmement variés pour bien que c'est
des animaux 1 c'est pas des fleurs
depuis quelques années le corail et
protéger un peu partout sur la planète
les importations sont très réglementées
mais à deux heures de route de paris
pascal coûtant a l'embarras du choix
[Musique]
nausicaa l'aquarium de boulogne-sur-mer
s'est spécialisé depuis quelques années
dans la reproduction du corail
[Musique]
en fait c'est tout simple c'est du
jardinage stéphane hénard le directeur
de nausicaa ne vont pas ces coraux les
échange contre des poissons que pascal
élèvera au trocadéro ça c'est pour nous
une grande partie de ce que vous pourrez
à planter si on a si on a la place pour
mettre tout
comme ça pour ses coutures now
maintenant quelques quelques semaines
celle là à huit semaines
la colonie au fur et à mesure elle va
coloniser le
ça vient de contre la piste est comme ça
en angola ou complètement l'api père et
elle disparaît comme ça c'est donc de
plantoir ça sert de support serre de
plantes war c'est ça qu'on va ficher
dans des corps ont fait un petit trou à
la personne par exemple et on va
afficher sa dedans et si un petit
morceau transparent qui restent visibles
parce que le colonisé par les âges dans
votre quelques jours sur le corail va
recouvrir sa qui s'alliera fois
on
après une leçon de travaux pratiques
parce qu'elle n'ait plus qu'une seule
question à se poser dans combien de
temps
l'aquarium du trocadéro pour at il lui
aussi exposé ses couleurs
on
[Musique]
on remplit un bassin de 1500 m avec un
tuyau d'arrosage et c'est parti
[Musique]
on apprend on ne peut pas monter le
niveau de plus de 50 cm par jour pour
une par rapport à des contraintes béton
pour que le béton se mettent en charge
progressivement donc il faut que le
niveau monte doucement donc 50 cm par
jour ça correspond à deux tuyaux comme
ça donc je vais mettre un deuxième
studio et savary remplir tranquillement
il nous faudra donc 50 cm par jour il ya
neuf presque dit m donc faire le calcul
ça fait je sais plus ça fait presque
trois semaines pour remplir le bassin
[Musique]
pendant qu'à paris le niveau monte
lentement de l'autre côté de
l'atlantique carlos et son équipage
poursuivre d'une pêche jusqu'au là sans
succès
soudain la ligne résiste
achat y en a là juste en dessous le
câble y lourd lourd comme une enclume
c'est un requin marteau de plus de 80 kg
vivant ce requin vaut plus de 15000
dollars
la plupart des aquariums rêve d'en
posséder un dans leur bassin mais celui
là finira sur l'étal d'un marchand
[Musique]
encore une nuit à attendre
pour augmenter sa chance car l'on sort
un atout de son jeu un seau plein à ras
bord de sang de boeuf
il sait que les requins en détecteront
une seule goutte dans des millions de
litres d'eau de mer à des centaines de
mètres à la ronde
et ils se rapprocheront
c'est confirmé carlos est en train de
croiser la route des requins en quelques
heures il en a pêché 3 mais ils sont
tous morts cette fois la ligne s'agitent
les parties
c'est décrocher il s'est libéré le
regarde il s'est échappé il reste dans
les parages regarde le regarde le je
pense que c'est une sorte de
décompression qu'il fait il prend son
temps avant de redescendre regarde il
est toujours là il va faire des allers
retours
et puis le descendance mais bon il a
réussi à se détacher il a gagné sa
liberté
une deuxième chance se présente assez
vite un requin de brice s'est fait
épingler il est petit donc transportable
[Musique]
pour le garder vivant il faut leur
montée sans le blesser et en même temps
faire attention à ne pas basculer
[Musique]
l'équipage est de retour avec toute sa
cargaison
à marée basse le bateau ne peut pas
accoster il faut transporter les prises
sur une barge pour rejoindre le village
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
com
[Musique]
cuerrier là mais elle verra le requin
plus tard pour l'instant c'est une
véritable attraction pour tout le
village
c'est peut-être le plus petit aquarium
du monde mais les visiteurs sont au
rendez vous
[Musique]
parmi toutes les photos prises ce
jour-là l'une d'entre elle partira en
courrier électronique à l'adresse de
pascal coûtant
donc pas maintenant c'est à moi de voir
si ces poissons nous intéresse
effectivement on l'avait mis dans notre
liste donc ça nous intéresse à savoir si
ça rentre encore dans mon budget par
rapport au tarif qu'en fait il ya deux
grandes familles de requins les requins
qui ont besoin de nager pendant le
transport donc là ils ont besoin de
beaucoup d'eau donc ça coûte très cher
au niveau du fret
puis après il ya les requins type
requins nourrices qui ont qui peuvent
respirer sans âge et donc là ça coûte
beaucoup moins cher
un requin ça comment ça je sais pas moi
et 2000 2500 dollars ou euros ce à peu
près la même chose et puis ça peut aller
pour les requins si jusqu'à 25000
dollars la moitié des requins du troquet
déroulé pesci dans leur environnement
naturel
les autres viendront du marineland le
célèbre parc d'attractions de la côte
d'azur
surtout connu pour ses orthez
apprivoiser
[Applaudissements]
mais le marineland est aussi le premier
au monde à avoir maîtrisé la
reproduction de requins gris et un se
lancer dans le commerce de jeunes
requins sous la conduite de john kerr
shao le secret de la collection de toute
espèce est un équilibre des paramètres
qui joue dans la production c'est-à-dire
le bassin quand pour beaucoup la qualité
de l'eau et les animaux présents il faut
ce qu'il faut il faut aux deux mâles de
préférence à peu près dominant est une
des femelles disponibles et adultes bien
sûr mais en âge de se reproduire et à
partir de là le cycle se déclenche une
fois que le cycle est déclenché il faut
essayer de maintenir l'équilibré en
permanence pour que la chose continue on
va choisir celle qui quitteraient
visiblement porte quelques bébés dans
son antre ça sent au bébé pour
printemps été 2006
l'équipe du marineland d'antibes a
tourné ces images exceptionnelles
la naissance d'un jeune requin
[Musique]
les bébés squale seront aussitôt
transférés dans un autre bassin pour les
protégés de l'appétit de la famille
[Musique]
pour assister un heureux événement au
marineland d'antibes
il faut un peu de patience à ces jeunes
que les villes la gestation d'un requin
gris dure une dizaine de mois parfois ma
pression telle que qui sont intelligents
interpharma pression qui pense pas c'est
ça qui est un peu difficile à savoir
mieux moi je trouve qu'il est en
activité qu'on les pêche de la nature et
qu'on les maîtres captivité là c'est
encore plus effroyable sous l'autre qui
sait pas que ce ne soit pas qu'un grand
large
[Musique]
à paris dans les bassins du trocadéro le
niveau de l'eau grimpent depuis dix
jours pour pascal l'heure de vérité
sonne tous les soirs
derrière ces murs des tonnes d'eau et
prouve l'étanchéité des bassins une épée
de damoclès
et bon là on est sur un chantier la
semaine dernière on a été voir avec
mathieu on a fait tout tout d'un coup on
a vu une grosse claque est un endroit
vraiment on a commencé à paniquer en
fait on a vu un gars qui partait en
remontant sa braguette d'abord fait si m
le niveau est là ce matin à 8h30 on doit
être à peu près quatre mètres 15 parlant
[Applaudissements]
que ce soit pour un aquarium de salon ou
pour un ouvrage aussi grand c'est le
même cauchemar qui menace
[Musique]
pour que l'eau bien ici
il y à l'urgence le spécialiste des
vitrages doit impérativement à courir
des états unis
[Musique]
deux jours plus tard voyons débarque du
colorado avec une pompe à silicone de la
teinture et l'humeur des mauvais jours
pascal formont décent
[Musique]
on venait se fout là bas c'est pas une
fuite je suis catégorique il n'aspire
pas la teinture la teinture était dans
le trou et quand j'ai mis le silicone
tout cas s'il y avait vraiment une fuite
la teinture disparaîtrait dans le mur ça
vient d'ailleurs derrière les rochers
c'est pas dans ce trou tu ne peux pas te
dire où il faut que cherche on n'est pas
à lui dit et on est dans l'eau on n'en
est pas loin et c'est pour ça donc pas
écoute on verra demain on saura demain
après midi
le lendemain les entrepreneurs et le
directeur de l'aquarium décide
d'employer les grands moyens
on va donc d'abord baisser le niveau
d'eau afin de détruire les décors
d'accéder aux étanchéité et des
appareils loués la fois notre notre
source d'attraction mais sera dans le
même temps du procès en deux
[Musique]
non il est ressorti par apport de 2
centimes alors que tous les autres sont
collés donc on peut avoir un problème de
fuite ici au niveau du donc je vais
dégager béton qui autour de ce match
quand on a fait la première couche
conseil se dégage ici mais on va
vérifier
est ce le cas c'est le deuxième décor
derrière en bordure si un anneau parce
que là il y en a aussi certainement ses
locaux tout en douceur autant ce serait
mûri fier et dans le deuxième des corps
tu vois pas trop perceuses des fois la
non j'ai pas assez dégagé ce que je veux
casser le minimum je vous traduis sur
pied cassé fiscaux la chance parce que
tu vois le pôle mer ni passings
ils ont traversé le podium en purée nu
polyane entre la résidents étrangers
oui donc automatiquement table le
contenu d'entre elles est vachement arf
lui avait dit je coule manier un trou là
je crois que c'est ça qui suffit pour un
trou là il ya des hommes n'ont pas été
contrôlés alors qu'ils avaient fui c'est
derrière au bout du bassin
si les mecs savent pas ce qu'ils ont à
contrôler non mais parviennent sur les
chantiers il faut quand même arrêter de
déconner je vais pas mettre un mec
derrière chaque mec pour qu'ils
vérifient le travail qu'il a à faire
les ailes qu'ils ont leurs jours qu'il
aura donné les instructions de faire les
contrôles et à tel endroit et je raconte
relate l art donné aucune instruction
ils doivent contrôler leur installation
sur le chantier aucun bassin est encore
prêt tandis qu'un peu partout dans le
monde
les poissons ont déjà pris la route de
paris
bon après on tue peu contournement
course après midi quand j'ai cherché les
poissons en lorraine qui si on va
regarder aussi les bacs dans la
quarantaine ce qu'on attend encore les
poissons du japon
de tahiti qui doivent arriver demain et
puis qu'est-ce qui est encore oui piel
brésil qui va pas tarder j'attends ça
faut que j'apprenne ce que j'ai pas
nouvelle au brésil des poissons
multicolores et des hippocampes vont
faire leur baptême de l'air
et qu'est ce que vous avez comme
cargaison a déclaré j'amène des poissons
pour l'exportation
le contrôle d'entrée de l'aéroport est
bref mais la procédure est suivi depuis
longtemps par le service ibama
l'institut brésilien de l'environnement
et des ressources naturelles
renouvelables
le rôle de l'ibama n'est pas seulement
de contrôler et on essaie de développer
aussi une sensibilité à l'environnement
en ce qui concerne les poissons
d'ornement
il est nécessaire que les sociétés
soient enregistrés auprès de nos
services
cette pêche doit être strictement
contrôlés il ya une demande forte et
nous sommes obligés de la surveiller si
par hasard quelqu'un essaie de se
soustraire au contrôle
ça devient du trafic et là nous
réagissons fermement
d'après les chiffres officiels le trafic
de poissons diminuent au brésil les
fermes aquacoles se multiplient partout
dans le monde
face à une pêche de plus en plus
aléatoire et difficile
à ce rythme dans une vingtaine d'années
les professionnels prédisent la fin du
prélèvement en mer tous les poissons
d'exposition seront nés en captivité
la facture de janvier pour l'os était
14000 euros
c'est pas tous impliqués sur le 90
revient sur europe 1 par un sens les
grands bassins
tu viens sur aucun banc attend pour
samedi deux heures tu peux malgré tout
les sens
[Musique]
ça c'est plus rocher au café
en fait c'est sur l'étagère nature en
la mairie de paris a signé une
convention avec l'investisseur japonais
de l'aquarium du trocadéro
c'est un dossier qu'elle suit avec
attention pour l'image de la capitale et
les préoccupations environnementales qui
accompagne aujourd'hui tous les grands
projets quand tu auras le niveau
au dessus de cette vitre en fait vous le
voyez en fait vous voyez les passerelles
à 10 cm sur les passerelles 2,4 millions
de litres c'est déjà des grandes et très
grandes capacités je peux pas dire de
déguisements bassin aquarium je parle
pas tu as un extérieur mais les
scénarios pour les orques mais en bassin
aquarium
on devrait avoir le plus grand bassin de
11 jours évidemment pour un écolo on
aimerait mieux que les animaux restent
dans leur milieu naturel qu'on les
laisse tranquilles d'une certaine
manière et qu'on accepte de se contenter
de voir des films de regarder des livres
en se disant que c'est normal qu'on ne
puisse pas avoir accès à tous comme ça
bon et en même temps il ya des réalités
qui font que les os ça existe les
aquariums ça existe et que ça n'a pas
que des côtés négatifs non plus parce
que quelquefois c'est là aussi qu'on
peut conserver des espèces qui
disparaissent dans la nature compte tenu
des niveaux de pollution que qu'elles
ont affronté passé
relativement peu jamais regardé les
premiers cartons arrive de tahiti du
brésil du japon et ils s'entassent dans
la réserve
il faut stocker les nouveaux
pensionnaires comme on peut en attendant
la fin des travaux
conditionnée sous oxygène
les poissons ont tous été affaiblie par
le voyage certains plus que d'autres
ok ces poissons qui sont très colorés
mais là ils étaient dans le noir donc
ils sont tous terme
une un peu fatigué le débat lévis si
quelques heures il va reprendre ses
couleurs là pour l'instant
il est un peu stressé ou la brûler les
ailes
cela ils sont pas y en a un qui vivent
là dedans mais l'ouvrir vite encore un
perroquet
ayé c'est bon
[Musique]
cinquième en national
leur action de 3
[Musique]
oui
les acteurs sont en coulisses mais dans
les bureaux de la production le scénario
piétiner bloque toujours sur la même
scène
[Musique]
une autre tuile d'enlever sa cause en
est rendue sous locale là il ya le tuyau
qui pénètre le voilà quelques chaudes
sur versets et on voit tout autour du
tuyau le sortir sur un thé d'accord
alors ça c'est clair
j'en suis pas sûr est-ce que c'est pas
un trou qui est plus bas et avec la
pression qui font la différence à casser
5 mètres carrés on n'est pas sorti de
l'auberge pour les refaire et au le
braquage
il faudra encore deux mois de travaux
avant que l'aquarium puisse enfin
accueillir son public
[Applaudissements]
les fuites sont un mauvais souvenir et
le film catastrophe laisse aux enfants
la place à la magie des fonds marins
[Musique]
des murs d'écrans projette des mangas
asiatique est définie aquatique
des images qui répondent au
chassé-croisé des poissons du monde
entier
il
[Musique]
pour admirer les requins les stars de
l'aquarium le chemin des visiteurs
passent devant les pensionnaires de
gérard garreau de nous ce jour y ait des
autres pêcheurs aux merveilles
[Musique]
tout est en place pour la visite
mais au bout de l'aquarium legrand bat
sont des requins et absolument vide
un problème de dernière minute pour
pascal coûtant l'eau est trop douce pour
les dents de la mer impossible d'y
plonger les squales il faut d'urgence
rajouter plusieurs tonnes de sel
donc le bassin et plus grande prévu pour
plus grand que les estimations qui
avaient fait des architectes et mon
fournisseur de requins donc le
marineland d'antibes m'a demandé à ce
que la salinité soit exactement 34
grammes par litre pour pour les requins
donc bah là actuellement on est à 30
grammes par litre donc il faut qu'on
rajoute par rapport au volume estimée
entre entre 8 et 10 tonnes on va dire ça
parce que ce matin on va rajouter
pratiquement des tonnes on va bien voir
à combien on arrive en salles unités
[Musique]
en provenance du marineland d'antibes un
camion roule depuis 16h sa cargaison
quatre requins et plusieurs milliers de
litres d'eau
[Applaudissements]
guillaume d'assistant de pascal coûtant
contrôler toutes les deux heures la
santé des squales qui doivent nager sans
cesse pour respirer
donc en oxygène 100 125 % sachant qu'il
faut être un peu de sang pour sang c'est
très bien et la température 23 points 3
degrés
un peu frisquet mais ça va
[Musique]
au petit matin les vedettes de
l'aquarium arrive enfin
les requins sont de retour quelques
millions d'années plus tard dans le
bassin parisien
allez
à les libérer le passage s'il vous plaît
attention
franck total à tête s'est passée ta sur
la tête contre le mur tation contre le
mur mais je tiens la queue
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ça y est le sous marin du trocadéro a
pris le large à quelques pas de la scène
l'élu blot dévoile à ses premiers
passagers une nature fragile et
envoûtante un monde d'eau salée cook un
spectacle n'a jamais su planter et que
les hommes s'acharneront toujours à
vouloir recréer
[Musique]